I'd like to introduce Christina to you.
She is our newest certified natural health professional graduate.
But better yet, she is our brand-new student services representative.
Welcome, Christina.
Thanks, Amber.
Hi! My name is Christina DeLong and I am one of the newest members here at Trinity.
I'm from Minnesota and Wisconsin.
I also help coach track in the local area...
...and I am very interested in anything that has to do with wellness...
...and I'm just very, very excited to be here at Trinity.
We're very pleased to have you.
Welcome to the Trinity family.
Please, everyone out there, be kind to Christina...
...as she's learning all of the ropes with Trinity...
...and she gets to know you better.